gasping for air
this child is in critical condition but
there's no ventilator
at this hospital in kabul
she's among thousands of newborns here
in afghanistan who desperately need
immediate treatment as i as you see it
here
is a child who is extremely premature
and he needs a constant supply of oxygen
and appropriate temperature in order to
survive
and in the absence of resources we
wouldn't have oxygen
incubators in this ward are in poor
shape
the shortage of masks gloves medicine
and baby food
her vitilis is the unicef representative
in afghanistan he is visiting this
hospital to see what are the most urgent
needs
delis is struggling to address the
ever-growing needs of health facilities
in afghanistan and with each passing day
afghan children are dying of disease and
malnutrition
well there is always life at the end of
the tunnel
and that's why we do what we do
if there was no life at the end
at the end of the tunnel we will not be
here
government officials have other
priorities taliban leaders are desperate
for international recognition and
financial assistance
but afghanistan's big donors remain
skeptical of the taliban in the meantime
the health system is on the verge of
collapse
doctors and nurses are brave they work
long hours but they are short-staffed
and overwhelmed with the number of
children
who are treated here every day and who
suffer from measles and malnutrition and
in many cases because they don't have
the right equipment they are struggling
to find the right words to tell the
parents that their children may not make
it tomorrow or the day after
ajmal habibi is a pediatrician
exhausted and helpless he and his
colleagues know there will be tough
times ahead this is very difficult it's
heartbroken for us because we cannot
help them
fuel and food will likely run out soon
if assistance doesn't arrive there will
be no electricity and heating in the
newborns ward
we returned to the same hospital two
hours after we filmed this child
her bed was empty she was too weak to
battle an infection that spread through
her body